vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
ça
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue pour deux
heures d'émission nous décrypterons
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités et nos reporters sur le terrain
tout de suite voici les grands titres de
l'actualité de ce mercredi 23 juin le
variant delta devraient représenter 90%
des nouveaux cas dans l'union européenne
d'ici fin août selon l'agencé sanitaire
une déclaration qui sonne comme un coup
de semonce alors que sa propagation
inquiète également l'exécutif gabriela
talent parle aujourd'hui de menaces et
de vigilance absolue jean castex et nos
ministes de la santé se rendront
d'ailleurs demain dans les landes
l'unique département pour le moment où
la situation sanitaire se dégrade
le ministre de l'économie français
interpellés par la gauche équatorienne
en cause les condamnations de l'équateur
à verser plus de 400 millions de dollars
à une filiale de la société pétrolière
franco britannique perenco basé au bar
hamas un archipel d'ailleurs inscrit sur
la liste noire des paradis fiscaux
depuis janvier 2020 par l'état français
l'ancien candidat de la gauche à la
présidentielle équatorienne audrey
sarrat on sera avec nous ce soir à 20h30
en exclusivité sur rt france
la sphère jamais laquelle shogi 4e
membres du commando ayant tué le
journaliste saoudien en 2018 avait reçu
un entraînement paramilitaire aux états
unis révélation hier du new york times
qui parle également d'une autorisation
d'abord accordé par l'administration
obama en 2014
cette formation s'est poursuivie au
moins jusqu'au début du mandat de donald
trump précise le journal
[Musique]
et
on aurait presque pu l'oublier le
spectre d'une nouvelle vague ressurgit à
l'issue du conseil des ministres le
porte-parole du gouvernement gabriel
atallah parler d'embellie sur le front
de la situation sanitaire tout en
rappelant les menaces que constituent et
le variant delta identifié pour la
première fois en inde
pour plus de précisions on retrouve tout
de suite mona mode et l'or en direct de
la place beauvau
soir mona gabriela talk il s'est donc
exprimé aujourd'hui et qui rêve it le
chiffon rouge exactement disons que
c'est un point presse qui reflète qui
refroidit après la fin du couvre-feu la
fin du masque les français semblent être
rattrapés par la réalité est justement à
lors de ce point presse traditionnelle à
gabriel attal a clairement indiqué que
ce variant doit nous préoccuper car il
est plus contagieux que les que
l'anglais l exécutif appelle donc à ne
pas baisser la garde d'ailleurs ils
représentent 70% à des contaminations
dans les landes écoutez le sur le plan
sanitaire l'embellie se confirme au
niveau national jour après jour et le
retour à une vie normale se poursuit
ensuite il ya la halle alerte qui est
liée aux variants delta vous savez ce
variant initialement détecté en inde est
considérée comme plus contagieux de
l'ordre de 60% par rapport à la souche
dit britannique qui était elle-même plus
contagieuse de 50% par rapport à la
souche initial les autorités sanitaires
internationales alerte sur ce point et
monaco représente au juste ce variant en
france
et bien selon gabriel attal il
représente pour l'instant 9 à 10% des
contaminations les autorités
internationales et bien elles sont en
alerte et ce qui est inquiétant c'est
que les chiffres changent assez
rapidement puisque la semaine dernière
olivier ferrand le ministre de la santé
évoqué une fourchette entre 2 à 4 % dont
vous voyez ça va très vite très
rapidement bonal à la reprise de
l'épidémie et tel donc possible si on
vous suit et bien à en croire le
porte-parole du gouvernement c'est une
possibilité car il représente une menace
et il n'est pas le seul à le souligner
puisque des chercheurs des médecins et
sim également que c'est une possibilité
alors pour l'instant parler d'une
quatrième vague serait un peu précoce
mais il faut rester vigilant et on l'a
vu dans le passé l'épidémie nous a
réservé bien des surprises
selon les professionnels et bien là vix
la vaccination serait un des moyens de
freiner l'épidémie et mona quelle
solution donc pour éviter cette
quatrième vague dont personne évidemment
dahan vire et bien pour l'instant
stéphanie pour contrecarrer une
potentielle reprise de l'épidémie
gabriel à tallard a indiqué qu'il
fallait protéger est les frontières à
l'heure où la france ne vit plus sous le
régime des couvre-feux l'exécutif et
bien redoute un relâchement général on
l'a vu d'ailleurs lors de la fête de la
musique le 21 juin
ou encore il ya à la finale de l'euro
qui inquiète également puisque plus de
soixante mille personnes sont attendues
dans les gradins en israël compenser
sorti d'affaires il ya eu la découverte
de deux kloster ovarian et delta les
autorités ont réintroduit le port du
masque dans certains endroits
alors la france ceux des confine à
l'heure où certains prennent très au
sérieux
ce variant delta la rentrée risque
d'être plus compliqué que prévu
merci mona amoud et l'or est ce variant
indien qui s'installe tout doucement on
l'aura compris en france donne
évidemment des sueurs froides à bien des
gouvernements sur toute la planète
clairement il fait planer la menace
d'une quatrième vague est la rentrée on
vient de le dire alors se mariant delta
va t'il nous pourrir l'été en france
est-ce que la traque est suffisante
sommes nous en train de reproduire les
mêmes erreurs que l'été dernier c'est
l'objet de notre décryptage ce soir et
pour en parler nous sommes avec philippe
froguel chercheur généticien professeur
à l'impérial college de londres et à
l'université lille 2 merci beaucoup
philippe froguel d'être avec nous à vos
côtés en direct de bruxelles laurent
alexandre essayiste et chirurgiens
bonsoir à vous aussi laurent alexandre
merci infiniment d'être avec nous ce
variant delta ça y est on reparle du duc
aux idées pas en bien évidemment ces
jeux c'est rarement en bien d'ailleurs
quand on parle de ce virus
il représente entre 9 et 10% des
contaminations en france c'est ce qu'a
dit le porte parole du gouvernement
aujourd'hui ça vous paraît laurent
alexandre être le bon chiffre où on est
en dessous de la réalité
je partage complètement l'avis du
professeur froguel sur le fait qu'on ne
sait quand ce passé les virus en france
donc nous avons des approximations au
lieu d'avoir des chiffres très dur très
sûr donc si nous voulons surveiller
mieux ce variant il est absolument
indispensable aujourd'hui de faire ce
qu'a préconisé philippe raud gueule
c'est à dire de multiplier les
séquençages arn de souche de manière à
suivre de façon très très très proches
et avec une bonne certitude statistique
l'évolution du variant de manière à
éviter une mauvaise surprise qui
pourrait se jouer les casse en arriver à
partir du 15 août fin août
à cette époque là on pense que le
variant delta sera majoritaire en france
et on voit qu'en angleterre il a
multiplié par quatre le nombre de
contaminations en très peu de jours donc
il y à un danger dans un pays la france
qui ne sera vacciné qu'à 60% probable
à la fin de l'été avec 40% de non
vaccinés il est possible qu'il y a une
petite quatrième vague philippe froguel
effectivement vous êtes un défenseur de
ce séquençage de la première heure même
question qu'est laurent alexandre selon
vous est ce que ça veut dire qu'on a
sous-estimé qu'on sous estime déjà ce
chiffre et que ça peut aller très vite
le seul chiffre qu'on avait été
probablement juste c'est 1% vers le 25
mai c'était l'été de flash la dernière
qu'on a eu
moi j'avais calculé ou pour vérifier sur
mes tweets qu'on devrait être de l'ordre
de 9 à 10% en ce moment j'espère me
tromper mais c'est aujourd'hui le cas
j'ai aussi hélas se dit écrit que si ça
continue comme ça on aurait comme
l'angleterre le 22 mars à j'ai vérifié
et c'est vrai le 22 mai ils ont commencé
à réaugmenter nombre de cas et ça
correspondait à 10% de variants donc le
10 % de monsieur attali
on ne pense pas que sais je sais pas
c'est vrai ou faux parce que je pense
qu'on n'a pas les moyens aujourd'hui
servant la réalité mais le jour où on
aura réellement dit pourtant l'aca devra
augmenter ça pourrait en juillet à début
juillet ou fin juillet selon la
seulement la réalité des chiffres
le gouvernement est complètement aveugle
aujourd'hui on n'en sait absolument rien
tout ce qu'on sait c'est que comme
partout et comme man u aldi nuage de
tchernobyl ça nous échappe pas à nous
comme de parce qu'on voit ce qui se
passe au portugal qui se passe en
allemagne et en belgique on aura une
augmentation pour savoir ce qui va se
passer c'est très simple il faut ré
séquences et avoir un un taux autant x
et avoir un temps un taux autant x + 7
jours et là on aura une grosse caisse
passé tant qu on n'a pas ça bien on joue
madame soleil
depuis le temps qu'on en parle on se
demande pourquoi c'est pas encore bien
en place il faut séquence est davantage
vous me le dis depuis longtemps regardé
ce tweet du professeur philippe juvin
chef du service urgence à l'hôpital
pompidou à paris
taj notre opinion trois leçons à tirer
vite de nos erreurs passées
il faut le surveiller en séquençant
comme le font nos voisins accélérer la
seconde dose de vaccin qui protège
traquer les cas isolé ces trois pistes
dans les landes un rappel à un cluster
de variants indien adac 70 pensant de
contamination le vaccin laurent
alexandre clairement et il une des
pistes les plus sérieuses pour lutter
contre ce variant il faut aller plus
vite dans la vaccination et notamment la
deuxième dose comme le suggère le
professeur juin évidemment il y a
toujours aucun traitement
tout le monde reconnaît aujourd'hui que
l'ivermectine la chloroquine ne
fonctionne pas donc notre la seule arme
que nous avons ce sont les méthodes de
confinement qui ne sont pas durables et
puis la vaccination pour ce qui concerne
le variant delta où on voit que la
protection est médiocre avec une seule
injection
donc lorsque le variant delta se
multiplient il est absolument crucial
qu'une partie importante de la
population et reçu les deux doses
d'autre part avec des variantes sont de
plus en plus contaminant qui diffusent
de plus en plus vite pour le dire
simplement comme le marié anglais puis
maintenant le variant indien le seuil
nécessaire pour avoir une immunité
collective ils montent mécaniquement
donc aujourd'hui on est très
probablement pas à 60% de 2,2 de
vacciner pour avoir une immunité
collective on est plus probablement
entre 80 et 85% qui sont nécessaires or
on voit bien que on a un vrai plafond de
verre dans la plupart des pays
occidentaux du fait des mouvements
complotistes anti vaccins et qu'on a
beaucoup de mal à dépasser 65 % même
israël et qui a été le leader mondial de
l'acquis nation est aujourd'hui à 63% de
vaccination et ne progresse plus ils
vont atteindre 64 65 maximum donc on
n'est pas suffisamment matinée un pool
de 40 % de gens non vaccinés avec un
variant qui diffuse plus vite comme le
variant delta et bien c'est le risque
d'avoir une nouvelle vague
alors est ce que il est difficile de
dire cette nouvelle vague va arriver dès
la fin de l'été ou si elle va attendre
septembre octobre
on est aujourd'hui dans une phase de
test décélération sort bleus 1 0 et tout
ap
il nous parle de la france bien sûr là
pas de l'angleterre donc on a des
raisons d'optimisme mais les données
anglaises sont inquiétantes et montre
bien que avec les données israélienne
que la vaccination à 60 65 % ne suffit
pas pour casser l'épidémie
quand on a des variants qui diffuse vite
comme le delta injustement avant de
donner la parole à philippe froguel
on va s'arrêter justement quelques
instants sur cet exemple israélien où
malgré un bol avait dit laurent
alexandre la rapidité la campagne
vaccinale le nombre de cas de
contamination est en hausse avec
toujours en cause ce variant delta les
détails avec médecine romagnan
l'inquiétude des autorités israéliennes
face au co vite 19 essais variant au
lundi 125 nouveaux cas ont été
répertoriés
alors qu'on comptait seulement une
dizaine de cas quotidiens cette dernière
semaine
la faute aux variants delta importés en
israël par des voyageurs
plus de mille personnes ont dû être
placés en quarantaine après le retour
d'israéliens parti à chypre
le premier ministre navin talibés net
appelle les voyageurs à la prudence et à
porter de nouveau le masque si vous
savez éviter de partir en vacances à
l'étranger
faites le si vous n'avez pas encore
réservé je vous recommande de ne pas le
faire à nîmes liszt à la fois au nom des
experts portons des masques de nouveau
en intérieur je demande aux ministres et
aux dirigeants à partir de maintenant
nous porteront des masques en intérieur
à l'obligation de porter le masque dans
les lieux publics fermés a pris fin il
ya seulement une semaine à l'annoncé de
la levée de cette mesure
des habitants de tel aviv s'était
montrée soulagée même si certains
restaient sceptiques
c'est génial on va au centre commercial
ont fait des courses et on n'a pas
besoin de porter de masque on peut
manger et boire sans rien sur le visage
donc c'est super on se sent très bien
[Musique]
c'est surtout effrayant de penser que la
morbidité va soudainement augmenté parce
que le nombre de masques à diminuer en
tant que médecin je fais confiance aux
autorités
je les ai cru durant toute cette période
car je n'ai aucune raison de ne pas le
faire tout d'abord on se sent libre mais
je pense que dans les bus il faudrait
quand même porter un masque car il ya
plus de monde dans les centres
commerciaux c'est parfait et on sent
qu'on reprend une vie normale la
vaccination a été ouverte aux
adolescents de 12 à 16 ans en israël le
6 juin dernier
naftali bennett a appelé les parents à
les faire vacciner le plus vite possible
les 10-19 ans ont été les plus touchées
par le virus ce mois ci plus de la
moitié de la population israélienne a
déjà reçu deux doses du c'est romantique
au vide
malgré cette récente hausse des nouveaux
cas le nombre de décès lui reste très
limitée avec un seul mort recensé ce
mardi philippe froguel plein
d'enseignements dans ce sujet déjà des
contaminations qui repartent à la hausse
on reparle de restrictions on s'inquiète
mais surtout en israël ont réagi quand
même de manière très rapide et de
manière significative est ce que c'est
la bonne méthode ils vont s'en sortir et
est ce qu'on n'a pas un petit peu un
train de retard en europe le cas il ya
des choses que font ils rien qu'on n'a
pas osé faire en france ou en belgique
ce qui a fait que par exemple si vous
êtes un soignant à il faut absolument
que vous soyez vacciner sinon vous êtes
durée de votre hôpital alors en france
je l' ai vu à au nord de la france on
l'a vu en belgique et des ehpad avec des
gens qui sont morts alors qu'ils étaient
vaccinés tout simplement parce que les
soignants ne l'était pas donc il faut
qu'un jour en europe pourra on considère
ce qu'il faut faire
le prix à payer est le prix à payer
c'est que tout le monde soit résigné on
arrête des imbécilités du
avoir des gens qui sont des soignants et
qui a un je ne sais pas pourquoi des
sites que eux ils ont le droit de
contaminer des gens âgés qui vous sont à
risque et là c'est quelque chose
d'anormal donc je pense que les
israéliens font ce qu'ils doivent faire
et on va voir s'ils vont réussir à
échapper à avoir des morts et des gens
l'hôpital avec ce variant delta qui
n'ont rappelons le est extrêmement
extrêmement contagieux et on va voir si
j'y arrive effectivement ça sera très
vindicatif des choses qu'il faudrait
faire en europe alors alexandre matin
sont au fait j'y vais parce que pour le
moment comme l'a souligné le professeur
froguel on sait pas encore si ça va
marcher en israël et on leur souhaite
évidemment et tout comme on nous le
souhaite en europe mais on a quand même
le sentiment chaque fois que l'europe
volailler et peine à prendre des mesures
très fortes et là je met l'europe en
entier dans le même panier on n'a pas
fermé les frontières très vite avec
l'inde à commencer par le royaume-uni il
faut frapper vite et fort dès maintenant
ça sera trop tard dans un mois
c'est compliqué les français sortent à
peine du confinement ils en ont marre on
est à moins d'un an de l'élection
présidentielle donc emmanuel macron ne
peut pas être trop castrateur parce que
si les castrateur il va perdre
l'élection présidentielle qui n'est pas
gagné pour lui donc on est dans une
configuration politique qui est
compliqué les français en ont
objectivement marc mais c'est pareil
ailleurs c'est pareil chez moi en
belgique
donc il va être difficile de mettre en
place des mesures autoritaires dès cet
été au moment où les gens volent au
contraire relâché la pression je suis
d'accord avec philippe froguel
là le fait que les soignants ne soit pas
vaccinés et suffisamment est scandaleux
il y effectivement des gens qui sont
contaminés par les soignants non
vaccinés et qui meurent du coc vide et
c'est inacceptable la vaccination doit
être obligatoire pour tous les soignants
quel que soit quelle que soit leur
catégorie et puis il ya un autre
problème inacceptable en france c'est
que si l'on prend les gens de plus de 80
ans ghana 22% qui ne sont pas vaccinées
en france c'est absolument inacceptable
que les gens qui ont un risque massive
de mourir du coc vide ne soient vaccinés
qu'à 78 79 %
on sait là je parle de la première
injection c'est un scandale il faut
obligatoirement alexandre dans ce cas je
pense je pense qu'il faut rendre la
vaccination obligatoire au dessus de 70
ans parce que le pourcentage de gens à
risque qui n'est pas vacciné aujourd'hui
est beaucoup trop important la
vaccination des enfants et des ados est
un problème difficile et très très
compliqué et et on aurait on aurait
besoin de trop de temps pour en discuter
en revanche l'obligation vaccinale au
delà de 70 ans et chez les soignants est
une nécessité pour éviter cette
quatrième vague
franchement aujourd'hui d'avoir 22 % de
jambes plus de 80 ans non vaccinés on
déconne à plein tube
c'est inacceptable et c'est absolument
scandaleux c'est en termes de santé
publique une énorme erreur et là dessus
le gouvernement a été trop laxiste
parce que il ne l a voulu donner des
gages aux complotistes anti-vaccins il a
flatté
il a flatté d anti vaccins aujourd'hui
il faut rendre obligatoire sur ces deux
catégories de population le vaccin c'est
inévitable sinon on va être à nouveau en
bété à la rentrée en tout cas le centre
européen de prévention et de contrôle
des maladies on nous annonce ce soir que
ce variant indien devrait représenter
90% des nouveaux cas dans l'union
européenne d'ici la fin autant cesser
demain la fin août clairement fini
programme ça ça va nous pourrir la fin
de l'été et surtout la rentrée tout
dépend du taux de vaccination si les
français font ce qu'ils ne font pas
aujourd'hui yens une prévost diminution
du nombre de primo vacciner disent qu'on
n'est plus qu'à 2 à 300 milles par jour
à est en fait la plupart des vaccinés
sont assez utile bien entendu d'aider
les gens de couleur deuxième dose mais
et un plafond de verre et on connaît
tous des gens pong est un jeune qui
refuse à se faire vacciner c'est ça
c'est absolument dramatique
moi si j'étais le gouvernement je ferai
une une campagne extrêmement agressive
pour pousser tout le monde à se faire
vacciner sert peu près la seule chose
qu'on peut faire en réalité parce qu'il
est tellement contagieux
le reste ça va balayer tout si on dit et
qu'il y aura 90 % de variants à la fin
août
on voit bien que l'on fasse on n'y
échappera pas donc si on veut pas qu'ils
aient des gens qui meurent et qu'est-ce
qu'on retrouve à l'hôpital où des gens
qui est des covin l'on est quand même 10
% après covin l'on a laissé les gens
sont très gênés une étude qui vient de
sortir qui vont quand même des anomalies
au niveau du cerveau de pas mal de gens
quand vie des idées déco vite donc on
sait pas trop ce que c'est ce que c'est
au long terme il faut vacciner vacciner
vacciner et je ne trouve qu'en france on
est un petit peu encore le vaccin
voyez les les les films c'est encore le
vaccin de la personne âgée vulnérable il
faut que tout le monde ce vaccin mais le
royaume uni laurent alexandre un
philippe froguel le connaît bien
puisqu'il y travaillent
également on voit que tu as eu voilà il
ya ce plafond de verre est présent aussi
au royaume uni qui a pourtant une autre
politique c'est un problème qui est
globale il n'y a pas et il n'y a pas
qu'en france qu'il ya des complotistes
anti-vaccins il y en a partout
on a une vraie difficulté on a 20 à 30%
de la population qui a été convaincu par
des gens comme alexandra aurions coude
associé à bigard à lalanne que le vaccin
est très dangereux allait modifier notre
adn allait dans certains cas nous tuer
on a vu à nos confrères marseillais
expliqué que vacciner les personnes
âgées
cette tête d'organiser un génocide
1 donc on a un certain nombre de
médecins onega qui ont tenu des
propositions sectaire complotistes
anti-vaccins complètement dingue est
complètement folle il n'y a pas eu
il n'y a pas eu de mouvements du
gouvernement pour lutter contre ces
complotistes fou et très très dangereux
qui sont en train de convaincre une
partie de la population qui ne faut pas
se faire vacciner
donc il est indispensable de lutter
contre les complotistes anti vaccins et
de rendre obligatoire la vaccination
pour les catégories dont j'ai parlé tout
à l'heure et d'inciter fortement les
autres catégories à se faire vacciner
rapidement parce que le philippe a tout
à fait raison
à l'heure actuelle on est en train de
tourner à 200 me
primo vaccinés par jour ça veut dire
qu'on est au plafond de verre et qu'on
va pas dépasser 60 de 65% en france or
avec le variant delta ça ne va pas
passer ce n'est pas suffisant avec le
variant delta le petit mot de la fin
pour vous fait des progrès majeurs
je suis d'accord il y avait rien à dire
de plus si les français ne se font pas
vacciner plus on va avoir des ennuis et
on n'aura peut-être pas énorme et en
plus de bord mais on aura des gens
auront des copines longue qui vont
souffrir
et pourquoi souffrir alors foncez
comment l'éviter il faut avoir deux
doses de vaccins particulièrement des
vaccins arn
il peut moderna ou pfizer et on est
quand même extrêmement 3 tg à quoi pas
de là le faire c'est complètement
stupide
merci en tout cas tous les remercier
infiniment fini progrès laurent
alexandre d'avoir été avec nous en
direct pour ce décryptage
on en vient maintenant à ce plan de
relance français validé par bruxelles à
il prévoit 100 milliards d'euros dont
quelques 40 milliards financés par des
subventions européennes elle la france
troisième pays à bénéficier de l'aide de
le derrière l'espagne et l'italie c'est
ce qu'a annoncé arsenal van der leyen la
présidente de la commission européenne
reçue à l'elysée par emmanuel macron
acte 750 milliards d'euros
du jamais vu depuis le plan marshall
c'est la réponse de l'union à cette
crise historique mais surtout aux défis
du futur
le changement climatique la révolution
numérique la concurrence grandissante
des pays comme la chine
nexcelle renew c'est le renforcement de
la compétitivité de la france et de
l'europe
alors je suis heureuse monsieur le
président chers emmanuel d'annoncer que
la commission soutient le plan de
relance français
ce plan va accélérer la transition verte
et numériques sur tout le territoire
je suis donc fière de vous transmettre
notre plein soutien
faisons ensemble de nationalisme ou un
succès pour la france les français et
l'europe un plus ancien candidat de
gauche à la présidentielle d'équatoriens
tendresse à hao sera avec nous on dans
quelques instants en exclusivité sur rt
france et pino viendront sur la sphère
jamais le sketch hoggy quatre membres du
commando ayant tué le journaliste
saoudien en 2018 avait reçu un
entraînement paramilitaire
aux etats-unis révèle assure hier du new
york times
[Musique]
il ne cesse d'augmenter et devrait
atteindre cette année 9 4% du pib
français
un record on parle bien sûr du déficit
public quand vous avez un déficit de
près de 10% et que vous allez faire
peut-être quatre peut-être 5% de
croissance
on n'en sait rien pour l'instant eh bien
vous êtes en récession de 6 quoi en gros
c'est ça que ça veut dire mais plutôt
dans une stratégie de dirigeants lahlou
15 après moi le déluge
mais le déluge s'il va finir par arriver
si l'on continue à voir ce type de
désinvolture et d'insouciance vis-à-vis
de la situation de nos finances
publiques qui a beaucoup d'activités qui
sont plus habiles bras et qui le jour où
il n'y a plus de n'ya plus dead vont
s'effondrer devons continuer à espérer
et dans l'efficacité d'un plan de
relance qui est totalement inappropriée
et totalement perpendiculaires aux
besoins de l'économie française
[Musique]
vous allez vous vous consacrez au
festival du film russe à paris qui est
intitulé quand les russes ne bouleverse
nous bouleverse toujours vous savez
parce qu'on les comprend pas il nous
touche
ils nous font pleurer et on sait pas
pourquoi l'objectif réel profond que
vous avez là c'est quoi c'est de faire
de la pédagogie c'est de faire mieux que
ça c'est de recréer des liens que la
politique n'arrive plus à rené malo
c'est à dire que la culture c'est au
dessus de tout ça le cinéma nous dit des
vérités que nous disent personne ni les
politiques ni les ambassadeurs ni les
journalistes et nous sommes rien c'est
la même culture c'est la même façon de
penser
les mêmes physique je pense qu'il ya une
union qui va se rétablir c'est pas
possible autrement
et de toute façon ils ont besoin de nous
comme nous avons besoin d'eux je suis
optimiste
peut-être pas tout de suite il faut
passer au delà de quelques quelques
obstacles mais je crois que l'avenir est
allemand
bienvenue à novossibirsk nous sommes au
bord de la volga le plus long fleuve
d'europe
nous sommes à chez vox harry
allons faire connaissance vous avez
choisi le jour à bagdad alors je suis
arrivé en 2005 pour l'étudier dernière
fois celle en profiter en 2011
elle ne demande pas un petit peu non ah
oui et c'est tous les fromages tous les
soucis sont toutes les les croissants la
pâtisserie traits de caractère des
russes qui te plaît l'amitié les gens
les gens très stylée les français ne le
savent pas je ne pensais jamais de ma
vie faire la plonge et autonomie vous
pouvez me souhaiter bon courage
à très bientôt sur un terreau france
[Musique]
le président français avait annoncé
vouloir créer un commandement militaire
de l'espace l'espace est devenu
complètement clé en termes à la fois
militaire et en termes économiques
l'espace et est devenu un lieu de
confrontation potentiel je pense que
militarisation ça veut dire que
finalement il ya un risque pour assister
à une guerre dans l'espace oui la guerre
est possible il ya de multiples façons
d'amener de rendre inopérant
effectivement des satellites
l'espace est encore un lieu pacifique
mais n'est plus que ça il peut devenir
effectivement un espace de confrontation
dans lequel des nations ou des groupes
peuvent intervenir pour détruire et et
causé des dommages considérables
20h38 les bienvenus en direct sur rt
france si vous nous rejoignez une partie
de l'opinion publique s'indigne en
équateur le mois dernier ce pays
d'amérique latine a été condamné à
verser 400 millions de dollars à une
entreprise pétrolière franco-britannique
sanctions fondées sur un traité
bilatéral signé entre quito et paris
problème l'entreprise en question dont
le grand patron est classé 14e fortune
de france en 2020 est basée aux bahamas
le résumé de la sphère en bref et en
images
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un an
[Musique]
à
oh
[Musique]
le
et l'une des personnes qui veut des
réponses dans cette affaire c'est andres
arauz économiste ancien candidat de la
gauche lors de l'élection présidentielle
équatorienne en avril dernier c'est
notre rubrique l'invité ce soir bonsoir
andrée zarauz merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france merci infiniment
mais infiniment puisque vous n'avez pas
accorder d'interview depuis l'élection
présidentielle d'avril dernier
aujourd'hui donc vous prenez la parole
en exclusivité sur rt france vous avez
récemment interpellé le ministre de
l'économie français bruno le maire pour
obtenir des réponses car vous dénoncez
une décision du tribunal d'arbitrage de
la banque mondiale décision qui condamne
donc un on l'a dit à l'équateur a versé
plus de 400 millions de dollars à une
filiale de la société pétrolière franco
britannique perenco en vertu d'un accord
entre la france et les couleurs ça et
l'équateur expliquez-nous et bonsoir
merci pour les maths invitation oui le
messieurs les maires la france et contre
les paradis fiscaux on a vu les pros non
seulement avec le groupe des sept pays
récemment et bien et perd un coût n'est
pas une entreprise les françaises ont
dansé et cassis les traités étaient pour
protéger investissements légitime non
pas des manipulations corporatives dire
milliardaire que monsieur pérol profiter
de perenco
c'est une situation qui est en croix est
en abuse de traiter et l'équateur ne
doit repayer pas cet argent parce que et
on est en crise très grave par la
pandémie et rendent montre que la
situation est indéniable comme jeudi
dans les tweets
justement vous le dites ans et cette
question de paradis fiscal qui vous pose
un problème et et vous écrivez aussi l
entreprise ne peut donc pas se prévaloir
du traité bilatéral d'investissement
entre l'équateur et la france c'est bien
ça ouais c'est
entre tech est signée entre paris c'est
quitte ou pas avec les bahamas alors est
ce que ces cas ci et c'est un cas de
critiques jean ping et sait comment ça
s'appelle dans la littérature et dans
les pratiques de manipulation coopératif
pour abuser les traités et des
protections d'investissement et ce
traité sont néocoloniaux néocolonial et
parce que ils ont le plus de droits pour
les corporations qui est pour les êtres
humains
alors on croit que c'est en abuse et la
situation pour le peuple équatorien
vraiment grave et les gouvernants doit
et revoir cette position est pas payé
cet argent pour perrin qu il a
suffisamment d éléments pour annuler et
l'arbitrage
alors andré sarazin rappelons que c'est
le gouvernement d' emmanuel macron en
plus qui a placé les bahamas sur la
liste noire des paradis fiscaux c'était
en janvier 2020 qu'est ce qui vous
choque au fond le plus dans cette
affaire mais je crois que c'est une
décision correcte et placer les bas
ramadan une liste noire des paradis
fiscal
et c'est la même chose en equateur on
doit pas faire que si l'équateur va
payer c'était 400 millions de dollars à
perenco bahamas et cet argent va pas
rentrer en france et les peuples frères
français souvent vont pas bénéficier et
de cet argent
alors c'est une situation que paris se
quittent audois et doivent et par les
échos bercy faut être ouvert une des
solutions et qui élimine les abusent de
treaty shopping des interprètes comme le
prennent qu'aux alors quelques jours
après l'interpellation en dhr nous le
maire sur les réseaux sociaux
manifestement toujours aucune réponse
vous êtes surpris du silence du ministre
de l'économie vous l'expliquez comment
les 400 millions de là elles sont
beaucoup d'argent pour un pays comme
l'équateur est peu mais peut-être sépare
est suffisant pour prendre la tension et
du gouvernement français et en équateur
et 400 millions de dollars sont et
presque la moitié d'un point de pib
et ça est une préoccupation significatif
pour nous j'espère que les gouvernements
français et analyse les traités entre la
france et l'équateur et trouve que c'est
traiter et abuser par perenco clairement
à ce que vous considérez que c'est un
dossier délicat voire embarrassant pour
l'état français
oui je crois que c'est impensable pour
l'état français pour l'état équatorien
et aussi pour tous les systèmes
d'arbitrage entre investisseurs et état
et domine en anglais et sts et c'est pas
possible que quand les mondes tout le
monde est dans une guerre contre les
paradis fiscal et on trouve que les
treaty shopping en utilisant les traités
de protection réciproque 10.6
investissements sont une élément de
cette guerre qui est pas être considérés
alors vous on l'a compris vous dénoncé
cette condamnation de l'équateur et
pourtant pourtant le nouveau président
équatorien a décidé lui de payer
mandingue et la sauve à verser les 400
millions de dollars à perenco
conformément à cette décision prise par
le tribunal d'arbitrage de la banque
mondiale
cela vous surprend il comme je dis je ne
crois pas qu'il est doit payer et ça
parce que depuis 2008
l'équateur n'est plus une partie de cire
dit que c'est l'institution d'arbitrage
l équateur a terminé le tvi avec france
en 2010 est alors il n'ya pas des
éléments juridiques légales pour payer
cette amende dans une crise et la
pandémie comme envie en équateur il ne
faut pas payer cet argent et il faut
destinée et ses ressources pour acheter
des vaccins
le gouvernement veut retourner à si elle
dit parce qu'il veut privatiser les
vraies structures prêtre pétrolière
électrique des télécommunications et les
autoroutes aussi aux entreprises
transnationales et c'est pour ça qu'il
est et veut retourner à cirdi il va
payer après une coupe pour montrer qu'il
est un ami des corporations
transnationales
mais c'est une haie et contexte où on
doit privilégier la souveraineté et la
santé du peuple et pas d incorporation
qui ont manipulé le système alors votre
camp à la gauche équatorienne elle va
jusqu'à contester la légitimité de cette
décision pour quelles raisons
oui bien sûr on va et quand on testé les
limites légitimité de cette décision et
il a beaucoup d éléments qu'on doit étre
était injuste s'est entraîné au colonial
mais aussi c'est un système et où les
arbitres sont toujours désignés et pour
l'autorité maximale des séries du
circuit
qui est le président de la banque
mondiale que c'est toujours un citoyen
et états uniens wii est presque toujours
un ancien ministre des états unis c'est
un système privatisées ou les appliquent
ce ne sont pas des juges
ce sont des arbitres qui sont pas assez
payés pour chaque cas ici ils sont
toujours du monde corporatif alors et
les règles sont injustes pour les pays
du sud et on va est contesté c'est et et
un monde aime toujours et on va et
défendre défendre les intérêts de l'état
équatorien et dernière question est ce
que vous pensez que la france devrait
faire de même cela pourrait-il remettre
en cause cette décision du tribunal
d'arbitrage
bien sûr il y à des pros non seulement
de l'assemblée nationale en france et
ancien prolongement qui dit que et
c'était système d'arbitrage entre
investisseurs et zetta est totalement
injuste on voit qu'elle a union
européenne a décidé qu'elle est traitée
entre pays européens et dont annulé et
on croit que cette décision doit être
impeccable aussi pour des traités est
entré les pays du nord et du sud et même
quand on voit que ce traité sont
victimes d'abus et par coopération et
comprennent qu qui sont constitués
domicilié et aux bahamas ou paradis
fiscal merci beaucoup andres art house
économiste ancien candidat à l'élection
présidentielle en équateur de nous avoir
accordé cette interview en français un
bravo pour votre foncé merci d'avoir il
dit sur rtl france
le new york times révèle les détails
surprenants sur des membres du commando
saoudien l'origine de la mort du
journaliste jamal khashoggi le quotidien
américain fiant que plusieurs d'entre
eux ont reçu un entraînement
paramilitaire aux états unis pour plus
de précisions retrouve notre reporter
thomas bonnin en direct de washington
bonsoir thomas cette formation
paramilitaire fait évidemment beaucoup
parlé et interroge oui c'est une affaire
qui risque de relancer la polémique sur
les liens entre ryad et washington on se
souvient tous évidemment du meurtre de
ce journaliste jamal khashoggi c'était
en octobre 2018 au consulat d'arabie
saoudite à istanbul un assassinat
perpétré par un commando composé de sept
membres qui étaient a priori
initialement destiné à la protection
rapprochée du prince héritier mohammed
mohammed bin salman alors ce que révèle
le new york times c'est que quatre
membres de ce commando ont reçu un
entraînement paramilitaire aux etats
unis une formation qui avait été
autorisé par le département d'état
américain en 2014 sous l'administration
obama
cette autorisation s'est poursuivie au
moins jusqu'au début du mandat de donald
trump
alors concrètement une entreprise privée
américaine a livré une formation à ces
quatre personnes ces entreprises se
nomme tiers one group et ses
représentants affirment aujourd'hui que
les entraînements portait uniquement sur
des techniques défensives en vue de la
protection de personnalités
selon le new york times il n'y a aucune
preuve à cette heure-ci que les
représentants de cette société où que
les autorités américaines est était au
courant des agissements des membres de
ce commando le département d'état
américain n'a pas souhaité pour l'heure
réagir aux révélations du new york times
se contentant d'un communiqué quelque
peu évasif
écoutez cette administration insistent
sur l' usage responsable d'équipements
américains et de formation américaine
par nos alliés et nos partenaires et
envisage des réponses adaptées si des
violations se produise l'arabie saoudite
fait face à des menaces significatives
sur son territoire et nous sommes
engagés à travailler ensemble pour aider
ryad a renforcé sa défense
mais forcément ces révélations jettent
le trouble sur ces formations donc
accordés à des entités étrangères sans
considération pour le respect des droits
de l'homme
il faut savoir qu'il ya aussi encore des
zones d'ombré dans cette affaire puisque
l'un des dirigeants de la maison mère de
cette société de formation paramilitaire
un temps été pressentie pour être nommée
au pentagone par l'administration trump
avant finalement que sa candidature ne
soit écartée enfin la position
américaine sur ce drame le meurtre de
jamal khashoggi est toujours aussi
ambiguë à l'époque donald trump avait
plutôt botté en touche prétextant ne pas
vouloir de mettre en péril les relations
commerciales entre ryad et washington et
joe biden à son arrivée au pouvoir après
avoir consulté un certain nombre de ses
conseillers avait décidé de sanctionner
les membres de ce commando
mais il avait épargné le prince héritier
mohammed bin salman alors que les
informations recueillies par les
services de renseignement affirment qu'à
minima le prince héritier d'arabie
saoudite était au courant de cette
opération contrairement à ce qu il a
affirmé en tout cas ces révélations du
new york times montre un nouvel aspect
des relations très étroites entre les
deux pays entre les états unis et
l'arabie saoudite rendant encore plus
compliqué une ferme condamnation des
agissements qui vont pourtant à
l'encontre de ce que joe biden a martelé
pendant tout son voyage en europe à
savoir la défense des valeurs
américaines en termes de démocratie et
surtout en termes de droits de l'homme
merci thomas bonnin en direct de
washington et on continue de parler de
cette affaire avec curro chamlou avocat
franco iranien bonsoir monsieur merci
avec nous cette autorisation une
formation a donné par l'administration
obama en 2014 puis qui continue sous le
mandat de trump parce que clairement
c'est une faute gouvernementale de la
voir accorder bonsoir merci de m'avoir
invité
je sais pas si c'est une faute
gouvernementales ou pas mais ce qu'on
peut savoir
on peut être sûr c'est que depuis depuis
des 31 depuis une vingtaine d'années au
moins une trentaine d'années c'est que
les saoudiens bénéficient d'une
formation aux états unis les les
militaires à messaoud ya tout ce qui est
de la police saoudienne peuvent aller
aux états unis pu aller aux états unis
et bénéficier d'une formation la france
sauf la même chose aussi les policiers
français forment des policiers étrangers
les gendarmes français forment des
gendarmes étrangers pour une fois je
vais défendre des américains c'est que
c'est pas parce que des militaires ou
des paramilitaires saoudiens ont été
formés aux états unis que c'est une
faute américaine
ils vont aux états unis sais pas s'il ya
des intérêts économiques énormes
gigantesque entre les états unis et
l'arabie saoudite et l'arabie saoudite
en fait il ya deux pays qui bénéficient
d'un pass 3 total aux états unis c'est
l'arabie saoudite et l'israël l'arabie
saoudite achète des équipements
militaires des sommes astronomiques aux
états unis et ils peuvent bénéficier
d'un pass 3 s'agissant tout ce qui peut
faire aux états unis tu peux revenir
tout à l'heure si vous vous posez si
vous me posez des questions sur les
attentats du 11 septembre justement qui
ont été commis par des par des saoudiens
effectivement s'en souvient je vous
invite à y revenir
tout à l'heure mais la question qu'on
peut se poser quand même c'est les états
unis ne ne craint-il pas justement que
ces formations puissent être utilisés à
des fins on va dire pas vraiment
approprié comme ça semble qu'il était le
cas dans cette affaire qu'elle choisit
on sait aussi que l'arabie saoudite est
impliqué au yémen c'est l'une des pires
crises humanitaires que a priori les
deux pays partagent pas vraiment les
mêmes valeurs
c'est pas moi qui le dit c'est ce sont
les états unis qui sont toujours
promptes à avaux là à remettre en avant
leurs valeurs morales voilà on peut
peut-être s'étonner quand même bon on
peut s'étonner mais il faut pas
s'étonner c'est parce que les saoudiens
achètent
je sais pas si vous venez d'un entretien
télévisé où il y avait le président de
la france et mbs le prince hériter qui
était aux états unis et le président
entend montrer que les l'arabie saoudite
allait acheter pour 100 milliards de
dollars d'équipements militaires à eux
donc face à cette somme gigantesque les
américains ne vont pas s'étonner ou ne
vont pas s'indigner devant quelques
quelques mâles fait que les saoudiens
vont commettre des saoudiens comme vous
et vidéo au yémen comme et et dvd moeurs
des assassinats la même chose aux états
unis comme ils l'ont fait pendant le 11
septembre les américains sont attachés
points et mains liées par les saoudiens
par l'argent des saoudiens et mbs
profitent de cet argent pour pouvoir
j'allais bien muselé les américains
c'est courant que des agents étrangers
reçoivent ainsi des formations
militaires sur le sol de ses alliés ce
qui ne pratique commune finalement c'est
une pratique très courante comme je vous
ai dit tout à l'heure il y à des
policiers des militaires étrangers qui
suivent les mêmes formations en france
vous savez que la france est un pays
spécialisé dans tout ce qui est lutte
antiterroriste surtout urbaine il y à
des policiers des gendarmes étrangers
qui viennent suivre des formations ici
en france et c'est la même chose qui se
passe aux etats unis parce qu'ils sont
compétents dans ces domaines là et on
peut pas savoir davance une fois que
l'arabie saoudite ou d'autres pays
étrangers on voit des militaires ou des
paramilitaires aux états unis qu'est ce
qu'ils vont faire après dans ce cas là
c'était des commandos qui allaient
assassiner des as qu'ils allaient
assassiner un journaliste saoudien à
istanbul et qui l'ont découpé en
morceaux mais les américains ne
pouvaient pas savoir d'avancé et si vous
allez faire ça ou pas c'est c'est
impossible de savoir
donc on peut pas reprocher à un pays de
former des militaires ou des policiers
et par avance parce qu'ils vont
peut-être commettre des actes
terroristes
après c'est impossible de savoir et
comme je vous ai dit les américains dans
ce cas là ils pouvaient pas
voir mais juste pour revenir sur le cas
durant sept ans vous savez que le
attentat durant sept ans a été commis la
majorité du commando étaient américains
saoudiens et les saoudiens n'ont pas été
poursuivis devant la justice américaine
et même l'ambassadeur de l'arabie
saoudite aux états unis a été reçue
quelques jours après par le président
bush en lui présentant peut-être ses
excuses ou autre chose mais laissa au
diable bénéficié d'un passe-droit total
aux états unis aux etats unis parce que
ailleurs c'est peut-être que compliquer
un certain pays comme notamment
l'allemagne un des pays européens ont
stoppé leurs ventes d'armes à l'arabie
saoudite en pleine guerre du yémen qui
tuent de nombreux civils
les américains ne commencent pas être un
petit peu embarrassé par cette alliée un
petit peu gênant notamment en termes de
droits de l'homme j'allais vous dire oui
il devrait être embarrassé mais les
américains sont plutôt ce qu'ils à ce
qui intéresse les algériens en premier
c'est l'argent et c'est la vente de leur
équipement militaire et il devrait
normalement gênés par ce parce prince
héritier qui commet des assassinats qui
fait des attentats et qui enclenche des
guerres un peu partout mais
malheureusement ils achètent énormément
d'armement aux américains est aussi bien
aux français et ils arrivent à s'en
passer
on sait que c'est lui qui a ordonné à à
peu près on est à peu près sûr que c'est
lui qui a ordonné le meurtre de cash au
guide et vous avez vu qu'en france on
entendre parler aux états unis on
n'entend pas parler et qu' il est même
invité au sommet g20 à peu partout dans
le monde même si on sait que c'est lui
qui commettent ces attentats
alors que si ça aurait été un autre pays
je vais vous dire parce que je suis
d'origine iranienne cité si sa aurais
étè
l'iran on les aurait banni du monde
occidental du sommet g20 est un peu
partout même des médias merci beaucoup
gauche convergent chamlou d'avoir été
avec nous en direct sur rt france non le
reste de l'actualité la russie affirme
avoir tiré des coups de semonce en
direction d'un navire militaire
britannique ons mer noire élevée
reproche d'avoir violé sa frontière de
son côté londres ni ses tirs
à moscou la correspondance d'antoine clé
à 11h52 heure locale lundi ce trailer
britanniques auraient pénétré dans les
eaux territoriales russe en mer noire
alors que le navire ne répondait pas aux
avertissements russe et bien d'après les
autorités un navire garde-côtes puis un
avion de chasse russes auraient donc
effectué des tirs de semonce en
direction du navire britannique soccer
et donc provoquer le changement de cap
du navire en question un incident
qualifié de provocation du côté du
ministère russe des affaires étrangères
le ministère russe de la défense a déjà
donné une évaluation des manoeuvres
dangereuses du destroyer de la marine
britannique dans la mer noire je tiens à
ajouter que nous considérons cela comme
une provocation flagrante de la part de
la grande bretagne qui va à l'encontre
du droit international et de la
législation russe
en outre je tiens à ajouter que le
ministère russe des affaires étrangères
convoquera l'ambassadeur dû royaume uni
à la suite de cet accrochage l'attaché
militaire britannique a donc été
convoqué à la direction de coopération
militaire mais pour londres
cela ne s'est pas passé tout à fait
comme ça en effet la défense britannique
assure que son avis en a été la cible
d'aucun tir et que le navire en question
ne faisait je cite que croiser dans les
eaux ukrainiennes cet incident met donc
en relief le risque élevé d'escaladé
militaire dans cette région du monde
une région dans laquelle des acteurs de
très nombreuses nationalités sont
présents on est resté avec nous dans
quelques instants notamment sur
l'audition ce matin de gérald darmanin
par la commission des lois du sénat le
ministre
d'ailleurs reconnaît des
dysfonctionnements lors du premier tour
des régionales et départementales et
puis nous parlerons du front républicain
qui se met en place avant le second tour
de ces élections un système notamment
contesté par les parties les plus
faibles
[Musique]
noël metz a exhorté certains pays
d'afrique à ne pas détruire les vaccins
anti qu'ovide périmés il faut craindre
une vaccination low cost en afrique non
une vaccination à l'est une vaccination
savez la vaccination ce n'est pas elle
n'a pas commencé avec la guitare
le problème ça reste quand même
l'approvisionnement reste que c'est la
faute des pays les plus riches qui
accapare justement les productions de
l'accent où est le mécanisme de la
vaccination vous savez ça a soulevé
beaucoup d'enjeux sur la question de la
solidarité si on peut en faire plus en
terme de solidarité de partage de ces
vaccins là c'est quelque chose
d'absolument important on sait que le
nigeria affirme qu'il élabore son propre
vaccin contre le convive 19 pour en
finir avec justement la dépendance
vis-à-vis des laboratoires à l'étranger
que ce soit le sénégal le nigeria
l'afrique du sud
beaucoup de pays en cette ambition-là
devoir amener l'agenda de la santé
publique au top des priorités c'est
quelque chose que nous saluons
énormément au niveau de l'organisation
[Musique]
l'article cet endroit où l'eurasie
l'amérique du nord et l'asie pacifique
se rend compte qu'on est en train de
devenir un lieu de tension majeure dans
l'équilibré géopolitique mondiale
l'évolution climatique laisse prévoir
que l'océan arctique sera totalement
libre de glace est ouvert la navigation
vers 2040 2050
il est clair qu'au delà de la route
maritime la fonte des glaces ouvre
l'accès à d'énormes possibilités
les européens comme les américains ont
tardé à prendre conscience des défis
économiques et militaires qui pointe
derrière l'enjeu environnemental plus la
glace fond et plus les appétits
grossistes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le président français avait annoncé
vouloir créer un commandement militaire
de l'espace l'espace est devenu
complètement clé en termes à la fois
militaire et en termes économiques
l'espace et est devenu un lieu de
confrontation potentiel je pense que
militarisation ça veut dire que
finalement il ya un risque pour assister
à une guerre dans l'espace oui la guerre
est possible il ya de multiples façons
d'amener de rendre inopérant
effectivement des satellites
l'espace est encore un lieu pacifique
mais n'est plus que ça il peut devenir
effectivement un espace de confrontation
dans lequel des nations ou des groupes
peuvent intervenir pour détruire et et
causé des dommages considérables
[Musique]
ses accusations elle pose quand même la
question du traitement ad décidant par
votre mouvement c'est des accusations
politiques qui n'ont rien à voir avec
les allégations portées devant la
justice espagnole
nous n'avons jamais expulsé les les
organisations des droits de l'homme ni
la presse alors que le maroc les ont
occupés aujourd'hui sont fermés est-ce
que désormais il ya un risque de voir
s'installer un conflit militaire sur la
durée les lignes rouges sont déjà
franchi quand la guerre a commencé après
que le maroc a annexé encore et partie
de notre territoire nous avons accepté
un plan de paix qui consiste à
l'organisation d'un référendum
d'intervention vous laisser les
sahraouis le choix de choisir le futur
de choisir entre l'indépendance et
l'intégration maroc à savoir que ce
n'est pas une partie de territoire
marocain
[Musique]
il ne cesse d'augmenter et devrait
atteindre cette année 9 4% du pib
français
un record on parle bien sûr du déficit
public quand vous avez un déficit de
près de 10% et que vous allez faire
peut-être quatre peut-être 5% de
croissance
on n'en sait rien pour l'instant eh bien
vous êtes en récession de 6 quoi en gros
c'est ça que ça veut dire mais plutôt
dans une stratégie de dirigeants lahlou
15 après moi le déluge
mais le déluge s'il va finir par arriver
si l'on continue à avoir ce type de
désinvolture et d'insouciance vis-à-vis
de la situation de nos finances
publiques qui a beaucoup d'activités qui
sont plus à huit bras et qui le jour où
il n'y a plus de n'y a plus d' aides
vont s'effondrer devons continuer à
espérer dans l'efficacité d'un plan de
relance qui est totalement inappropriée
et totalement perpendiculaires aux
besoins de l'économie française
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous merci nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième heure d'émission tout de
suite voici les titres de l'actualité de
ce mercredi 23 juin le ministre de
l'intérieur reconnaît des
dysfonctionnements lors du premier tour
des régionales et départementales géré
un terme à l'un était auditionné ce
matin par la commission des lois au
sénat après notamment les manquements
dans la distribution des professions de
foi des candidats les élections
régionales toujours et le front
républicain qui se met en place pour le
second tour ce dimanche c'est le cas de
la région paca où la gauche s'est retiré
au profit du président renaud muselier
qui affrontera thierry mariani face à ce
front
d'autres partis optent pour des
alliances loin de faire l'unanimité
c'était il ya cinq ans jour pour jour le
référendum du brds excite 52% des
électeurs britanniques voter alors en
faveur de la sortie du royaume uni
l'union européenne si le divorce est
aujourd'hui effectif et que la page
s'est tournée non sans mal la vie des
britanniques n'a pas changé le break
site a cependant ravivé des tensions
notamment en irlande du nord
[Musique]
les mercenaires étrangers pourrait
quitter prochainement la libye
déclarations de la ministre des affaires
étrangères du pays depuis berlin où se
déroule un nouveau sommet international
pour s'amener à consacrer à son avenir
elle met en avant des progrès dans les
pourparlers de paix la réunion regroupe
les principaux pays impliqués dans le
conflit en présence et ça c'est une
première du gouvernement de transition
libyen
[Musique]
le ministre de l'intérieur reconnaît
donc des dysfonctionnements lors du
premier tour des régionales et
départementales dimanche dernier gérald
darmanin était auditionné ce matin par
la commission des lois du sénat pour
s'expliquer sur les ratés notamment dans
la distribution des professions de foi
des candidats précisions sur place des
stèles farges
oui il y a eu des dysfonctionnements
c'est ce qu'a reconnu un gérald darmanin
lors de son audition par la commission
des lois du sénat le ministre de
l'intérieur qui a été interrogé pendant
un peu plus d'une heure a été confronté
en début d'audition au asie maj de
bulletins de vote brûlé par exemple en
haute savoie ou éparpillés sur la route
dans l'eure sur les raisons de ces
dysfonctionnements
gérald darmanin a rappelé le défi
logistique que présentait est cette
double élection précisant que le pays
n'en avait pas organisé depuis 1986 il a
aussi évoqué un potentiel manque est
d'expérience de la part de l'un des
fournisseurs en charge de la
distribution à des professions de foi
prestataires qui se nomme adrexo et
gérald darmanin qui a estimé il l'a
rappelé plusieurs fois en ca
dysfonctionnements ne sont pas les seuls
responsables de l'abstention record du
premier tour de ces élections régionales
et départementales
quant aux autres solutions envisagées le
ministre de l'intérieur a évoqué
plusieurs pistes je propose de l'écouter
je pense qu'il faudrait des dates dans
la distribution pour telle ou telle
élection ils ont passé une semaine avant
qu'un jour avant faudrait ont décidé de
savoir quel meilleur moyen pour la
participation afin peut-être d'assurer
un moment de rattrapage par la société
ou par l'état si jamais on n'est pas
reçue la propagande premièrement cette
date n'existe pas donc on ne peut pas
l'imposer aux missionnaires du marché je
crois que ce qui ce qui serait le plus
ce qui serait le plus efficace
bien évidemment ce serait de pouvoir
considérer que lorsqu on distribue la
propagande électorale on puisse à mettre
à disposition aussi des électeurs y
compris le jour du vote je ne suis pas
certain monsieur le président et sa
suite avant tout à fait prêt à y
répondre puisque l'eau s'y intéressaient
cette question dès ma nomination que
nous aurions pu changer grand chose vu
les décisions dictées par les mesures
sanitaires
et dont chacun se rappelle à l'époque la
grande question qui se posait pour la
tenue de ces scrutins
et donc j'ai rappelé que beaucoup de nos
pays voisins avaient remporté ces
élections je suis pas certain que nous
aurions pu faire absolument mieux avec
les impositions de marché et les règles
sanitaires qui nous est imposé gérald
darmanin qui a aussi indiqué que les
deux prestataires faisait leur maximum
pour que ces dysfonctionnement ne se
reproduise pas a lors du second tour du
second tour mais il a aussi prévenu un
il est évident que 100 % de la
distribution de la propagande électorale
ne pourra être assurée des explications
qui était à très attendu par la
commission à des lois nous attendons
beaucoup de vous ce matin a par ailleurs
indiqué le président de la commission en
début d'audition est la commission des
lois qui devraient à présent entendre
les patrons de la poste et d'adrexo sur
ces différents à dysfonctionnements donc
qui ont entaché le premier tour des
élections départementales et régionales
et adrexo sociétés ont privé en charge
de la distribution des plis électoraux
elle se défend je vous propose d'écouter
philippe voulait délégué syndicat
central à la confédération autonome du
travail d'adrexo il ya quand même une
majorité des français qui ont aussi eu
la propagande électorale avec son
interview est d'ailleurs que sûr cette
région là sur l'ensemble de la france
donc on peut pas dire que le l'opération
nepad été complètement mener mais
effectivement des personnes ont pu
constater que la propagande n'avait pas
été distribués ou avaient été distribués
car activement en ce qui concerne les
retards ils sont pour la plupart des cas
ils ne sont pas inhérents fonctionnement
d'alric sommet a plutôt au
fonctionnement en amour de la production
des plis qui sont arrivés relativement
tard dans les agences adrexo pour être
distribué en ce qui concerne la non
distribution ou pointant du doigt un
choix stratégiques de la direction qui a
été de recourir massivement à des
recrutements d'intérimaires plutôt que
d'employer le personnel fixe d'adrexo et
ce sont des personnes qui
allez peut-être beaucoup de bonne
volonté mais qui n'étaient pas formés
qui ne connaissait pas notre métier de
la distribution et qui sont arrivés avec
des voitures personnelles plein depuis
sur des communes qui ne connaissaient
pas forcément très bien avec des plans
souvent assez imprécis et polluent
beaucoup de mal à exécuter cette mission
sur le terrain des élections régionales
et les dernières retrait et alliances
qui se sont scellées hier certains pour
former ce que les parties continuent
d'appeler un front républicain
mais sur le terrain le front semble
davantage s'apparenter à un front anti
mélenchon que ce soit à droite comme à
gauche les partis politiques semblent
avoir trouvé elles mêmes arguments
contre le leader de la france insoumise
on lui reproche notamment ses positions
sur la république la laïcité ou le
complotisme à quatre jours du second
front tour pardon des régionales le mot
d'ordre est de faire barrage à la gauche
radicale quoi qu'il en coûte
et pour en parler nous sommes en direct
avec virginie martin politologue
professeur à la quête sur business
school bonsoir virginie martin merci
d'être avec nous alors on connaissait
ans c'est vrai le front républicain
contre le rassemblement national
cette régionale voit désormais un front
anti extrême gauche
oui c'est un petit peu ça en
ile-de-france l'alliance donc de bayou
pulvar et donc clémentine autain pose
problème donc avec visés en priorité
donc et monte il est hautain qui
représente la france insoumise et
certains mais pas simplement à la droite
de la droite mais aussi dans une
certaine gauche disent c'est
insupportable
on peut pas il met en fait de haddou de
l'extrême droite et l'extrême gauche
alors justement un parmi eux à vous
citiez à même la centre gauche la social
démocratie comme on l'appelle manuel
valls ont fait partie ancien premier
ministre on propose d'écouter son son
commentaire avant de vous faire réagir
pas une voix pour cette alliance avec la
france insoumise il ya des gauches
irréconciliables et l'alliance avec le
parti de jean luc mélenchon est une
faute politique et morale c'est bien ça
qu'il s'agit virginie martin ce sont des
gauches
réconcilia vous êtes d'accord avec cette
analyse de l'ancien premier ministre
c'est difficile parce que le parcours de
manuel valls eux qu'ils tournent un peu
le doigt la france ont dans l'eau en
espagne et qui maintenant revient voyez
le l'émetteur n'est n'est pas le plus
légitime ça s'est compliqué déjà
maintenant d'autres que lui ont pu dire
par le passé que c'était des gauches
irréconciliables
et d'ailleurs ça pose le problème
vraiment idéologique de caisse que la
gauche qu'est ce qu'être de gauche
est ce que la gauche s'arrête
effectivement à la porte de d'une france
multiculturelle par exemple pour
interrogation est-ce que ça s'arrête à
la porte d'une france trop féministes
pour interrogation
donc il ya tout cela et là tout d'un
coup on se retrouve avec une gauche un
peu tiraillé
et c'est très compliqué c'est très
compliqué mais c'est étonnant je vous
avoue aussi que même moi spécialistes ne
m'attendais pas à un front aussi fort
anti la france a soumis ce bail ou
pulvar je le trouve très fort très
radicale et là on voit bien qu'il ya
tout d'un coup quelque chose un curseur
notamment autour de la question de
l'islam qui se ré embrase et qui i
series un petit peu le débat
effectivement maillage valls qui parle
carrément de faute morale on imagine
qu'il fait référence à ce que vous nous
dites voilà les accusations on va voir
cette photo de l'islamo gauchisme qui
ont voilà qui ont été un petit peu
qu'ils ont tourné autour d'europe
écologie les verts notamment autour
d'audrey pulvar il ya eu plusieurs
polémiques
on peut comprendre peut-être qu'un
candidat de gauche un peu centriste en
simple socialiste voilà plutôt modéré
puisse faire des bons quand ils voient
cette photo de ces trois candidats est
ce qu'on est plus dans le partage voilà
des valeurs républicaines c'est en tout
cas ce que certains semblent leur
reprocher c'est à dire que voilà qu'est
ce que la république française qu'est ce
que l'universalisme la française c'est
là dessus que ces gens là
ce s'arc boute en disant nous ne sommes
plus là dans l'universalisme à la
française mais qu'est ce que cet
universalisme célébrer question qu'il
faut se poser ce sont des questions de
philosophie politique assez complexe
mais aujourd'hui les eaux qui essaye de
dire un petit peu de choses que cet
universalisme à la française doit peut
être aussi un peu plus s'ouvrir et
effectivement aujourd'hui ils sont trés
diaboliser ils sont montrés aussi du
doigt dans les universités par exemple
par frédéric vidal par jean michel
blanquer ministres éducation nationale
et de la recherche
donc oui il ya une espèce de chasse aux
sorcières si je puis dire sur les gens
qui travaillent sur l'antiracisme cesser
la question du genre voyez l'écriture
inclusive est ce que les réunions où il
y a que des femmes que des hommes que
des noirs ou pas des noirs etc
voilà c'est tout cela qui interrogé
aujourd'hui mais au lieu que ce soit
interrogé sereinement
c'est très hystériser et ça c'est quand
même un problème on pourrait aussi
écouter quelque chose est ce que demain
après demain
la france est même aujourd'hui est ce
qu'elle n'est pas multiculturel voilà
c'est toutes ces questions et je trouve
un peu dommage qu'à la faveur d'un débat
électoral et politiciens on occulte ont
fait que ces questions de fond qui sont
très importantes
au-delà de cette alliance 1 en ile de
france il ya aussi la figure de jean luc
mélenchon virginie martin qui est
particulièrement visée il dérange and
gauche comme à droite jean-luc mélenchon
parce qu'il ya eu d'autres alliances a
clairement dans d'autres régions contre
la france insoumise et ce qu'elle
incarne peut-être via jean luc mélenchon
ces briques la figure comme ça très
charismatique très personnelle de la
foncière soumises via jean luc mélenchon
plus être un problème peut être prêt
mais nous sommes à main des gens de la
faune sont soumises d'aucuns disent que
c'est trop que c'est pas forcément une
bonne incarnation non en même temps
c'est toujours l' équilibre subtil en
politique sans mélenchon est ce que la
france insoumise
serait aussi est aujourd'hui vous voyez
c'est c'est toujours le problème c'est à
la fois la solution mais aussi peut-être
le frein à la solution est l'obstacle in
fine et donc ça c'est un problème et
puis aussi l'ambiguïté on a entendu des
propos de hidalgo il ya quelques mois
quelques années qu'ils disaient tous
savent jean luc mélenchon est
aujourd'hui via audrey pulvar elle est
ok pour une alliance avec mélenchon et
la france insoumise
donc tout ça est complexe à demande
aussi plus d'apaisement plus de clarté
et qu'est ce qu'être de gauche
aujourd'hui c'est une vraie question
c'est une vraie question il faut que la
gauche la pause ce n'est plus possible
comme cela de louvoyer et de ne pas
poser la question les yeux dans les yeux
complètement et si la gauche doit se
fracturer entre une partie va lé ciel 26
qui s'est fracturé depuis longtemps
puisqu'il est plutôt pro macron de toute
façon et puis une autre gauche et bien
que les choses si les choses devaient
être ainsi qu'elle soit faite ainsi
alors il n'y a pas qu'à gauche à droite
ça grince des dents aussi évidemment
mais ça c'est pas une nouveauté ça
revient à chaque élection je vous
propose d'écouter julien sanchez maire
est reine de beaucaire porte parole du
rassemblement national et tête de liste
gardoise aux élections registre régional
en occitanie je souhaite que ce front
républicain soit mort ces gens ça semble
non pas pour des convictions mais
uniquement pour des postes et pour
laisser entre eux des gens qui se
partagent le pouvoir depuis des années
clairement virginie martin on comprend
que ça énerve un petit peu les
responsables politiques du r'n à chaque
fois ces alliances pour les empêcher
entre guillemets d'exister et
et de gagner oui bien sûr c'est
compliqué mais c'est aussi pour les
parties plus traditionnels là il s'en
sort très bien sorti sur ces régionales
pour l'instant en tout cas on verra le
deuxième tout mais comme si un clivage
gauche droite était en train de renaître
un peu de ses cendres
donc quelque part ils n'ont pas du tout
envie de rôle et c'est de laisser la
porte ouverte à que ce soit la
république en marche d'ailleurs où le rn
de l'autre côté
donc oui bien entendu il serre les
coudes et il faut des alliances alors
elles sont souvent effectivement contre
nature c'est difficile
en paca on le voit un électeur sur deux
de fait lydia dit ici ou là qui veulent
en tant qu'ils ont port très envie de
voter pour la droite de muselier c'est
très compliqué néanmoins laissé aussi la
porte ouverte aux arènes sur des
régionales bien sûr qu'il ya un côté
démocratique
mais le mode instructeur en france c'est
gagner au deuxième tour c'est pas gagné
au premier c'est gagner au deuxième tour
ça veut dire rassemblé additionnés et
être capable vraiment de fédérer donc là
on retombe sur l'éternel plafond de
verre du front national du front
national du rassemblement national dont
on parle beaucoup depuis des années mais
la france est ainsi c'est le mode de
scrutin sont fait ainsi et effectivement
il faut savoir passer le 10ème tour et
donc avoir des amis et des alliés
bon c'est un problème deuxième chose
donner une région où rassemblement
national et par exemple ne pas se
désister ne pas se retirer comme la
gauche a failli de fer en paca et bien
c'est aussi donner un tremplin
formidable financier politique de réseau
à une marine le pen pour la
présidentielle à venir
bon c'est aussi un choix 2
présidentielle ce n'est pas un choix
neutre une région c'est beaucoup
d'argent beaucoup de réseaux beaucoup de
dents de prison d'ancrage local mais
aussi du coup nationale virginie martin
vous restez avec nous parce qu'on va
continuer à parler de ces régionales
avec vous le savez évidemment l'une des
vedettes de ce premier tour c'est bien
évidemment l'abstention un banc
gouvernement avait décidé de réagir il
veut
notamment inciter les jeunes à aller
voter dimanche pour le second tour des
régionales
marlène schiappa d'ailleurs annoncé
l'arrivée d'une campagne de
communication est clair sur les réseaux
sociaux
selon les derniers chiffres 80 2% pour
rappel des 18-35 ans on ne se sont pas
déplacés aux urnes dimanche dernier
66,72 % pour l'ensemble de la population
soit un record depuis le début de la
vème république en 1958 et on vous
retrouve donc virginie martin 7
abstentions clairement et la lutte un
que veut mener le gouvernement en faveur
du vote des jeunes les réseaux sociaux
c'est le bon moyen d'y arriver là comme
ça en dernière minute c'est au télé sont
de toute façon tout est intéressant dans
ce sens là et puis il faut atteindre de
façon toutes les populations et le plus
possible donc c'est intéressant
maintenant vous savez entre le premier
et deuxième tours ce notamment sur des
régionales il ya souvent aussi un petit
sursaut de participation parce que les
choses se sont éclaircies
il ya plus de clarté on voit mieux les
duels où les triangulaires
vous voyez donc la lecture est plus aisé
et ça c'est important
donc on peut toujours on a vu un déjà
passé des sursauts de participation sur
des régionales donc je trouve que le
gouvernement se mobilise là dessus c'est
une bonne chose bien entendu mais après
les questions de fond c'est pas une
campagne éclair sur des réseaux sociaux
qui vont résoudre de gazole et les
problèmes de fond qui explique cette
abstention structurel puisque 14 elle
conjoncturelle elle est devenue
structurelle est de plus en plus
importante
les explications c'est quoi ces
le des hameaux le désintérêt un petit
peu des deux c'est compliqué c'est très
compliqué d'abord c'est la méfiance
c'est la défiance c'est l'absence de
confiance c'est la déception mais c'est
aussi l'impression si vous voulez que le
politique ne peut plus tellement de
choses pour nous et là c'est moi ce que
j'appelle un peu la fin du politique
point d'interrogation
qu'est ce que vous faites quand vous
savez que amazon google et cetera sont
plus forts que certains gouvernements au
monde comment faire ça quand vous savez
que amazon pèse plus lourd
financièrement que le maroc
qu'est ce que vous voulez faire avec ça
donc c'est des interrogations très
profondes qu'il faut mener maintenant
qu'est ce que le politique qu'est ce que
la fin du politique ou qu'est-ce que le
renouvelle le renouveau du politique
le politique est campé dans le temps et
dans l'espace
quand c'est énorme entreprise sont très
rapides et l2 sont transfrontières donc
le politique a vraiment un problème avec
ça vous voyez là je n'ai pas ouvert
ouvrir tout ça mais c'est un gros
problème de philosophie politique donc à
l'état est le politique aujourd'hui il
est très abîmé alors les jeunes actifs 1
25 34 ans deux études publiées par le
monde à 7 en avril dernier établissait
que les 25 34 ont fait du rn leur choix
numéro un
ceci explique cela les jeunes qui sont
pas venus le mauvais score du r n est ce
que ça peut poser bien sûr bien sûr et
un sursaut de participation peut tout à
fait bénéficier ou est reine parce que
vous avez deux types de population qui
se mobilisent très peu d'une manière
générale ce sont les jeunes et puis ce
sont les catégories populaires et nous
demande parmi les ouvriers
ce sont deux populations qui soutiennent
relativement bien
le rassemblement national donc il faut
voir aussi si vous voulez qu'ils votent
la plupart du temps ce sont des
personnes plutôt âgées un peu quatre
cadres sup
des retraités les gens de droite
les diplômés dont vous voyez c'est pas
là dessus que le sursaut de
participation va se faire quelque part
mais effectivement sur les jeunes les
catégories populaires
ça c'est très important et ça peut un
peu peut-être créer des surprises
alors les jeunes aussi aujourd'hui il ya
aussi maintenant une offre politique qui
est apparue depuis quelques petites
années et qui leur plaît c'est
évidemment europe ecologie les verts
donc on voit aussi que par ce sursaut de
participation même si les 2 3 4 5 points
ça peut aussi créer quelques petites
surprises la dernière petite question
gebre natale qui s'est dit ce matin
favorable au vote électronique c'est
peut-être un début de solution non
c'était le vote électronique début de
solution il ya tellement de théories du
complot on va dire que les élections
sont truquées ça va être une catastrophe
mais néanmoins on peut avoir le vote je
sais pas plus facilement par exemple
étalés sur deux trois jours on peut
avoir un vote par correspondance comme
aux états unis
voilà il peut y avoir des solutions il
est impératif de les trouver
aujourd'hui on vit à distance en
permanence avec nos objets connectés
et puis le vote à quelque chose
d'excessivement archaïque
alors c'est très bien les plus âgés un
encore ce rituel aller sur le préau de
l'école allé en mairie le dimanche matin
à la fraîche etc
mais les générations plus jeunes qu'il
ya quelque chose qu'on ne comprend plus
si je puis dire
et là il est très très jeune le clos
comprennent encore moins alors que d'un
clic sur internet
ils ont le monde à portée de main donc
c'est très compliqué ce rituel un peu à
l'ancienne
il est à la fois très charmant très
civique mais aussi un peu désuet et
peut-être plus très adapté pourquoi ne
pas faire des élections sur deux trois
jours est allé comme ça se fait dans
d'autres pays
et on semaine merci beaucoup virginie
martin d'avoir été avec nous en direct
sur rt france sur le front judiciaire un
procès aujourd'hui celui qui oppose le
magazine valeurs actuelles à daniel
bono l'hebdomadaire est jugée après la
publication d'un article de politique
fiction en août dernier la députée de la
france soumise étaient représentés en
esclaves sourire aux lèvres danièle
obono s'est présenté devant le palais de
justice de paris soutenu par de nombreux
élus et député du mouvement dirigé par
jean luc mélenchon comme adrien
maintenance ou encore mathilde de
panneaux aujourd'hui c'est quelque chose
d'important pour moi personnellement
intimement
mais je crois aussi pour nous tous et
toutes on vit en ce moment dans un
contexte qui n'a fait que s'aggraver en
fait depuis depuis août dernier
depuis que beaucoup s'étaient exprimés
en étant choqué par les propos les
images qui me liait et qui jouait de
tous les ressorts des delà des fantasmes
et de l'imagerie raciste et xénophobe
les autres procès aujourd'hui qui s'est
ouvert ce matin celui de clément f gilet
jaune frappé au sol par un policier le
18 janvier 2020 en marge d'une
manifestation accusé lui même de
violence envers les forces de l'ordre
les réquisitions sont tombées au
tribunal de paris les précisions de
notre reporter katia technique
le jeune homme a été condamné à six mois
de prison assortis d'un sursis simple
puisse 2000 euros en réparation pour
l'un des policiers 600 euros pour un
autre et plus de 15000 euros à l'agent
de l'état pour l' incapacité temporaire
de travail d'un policier le jeune homme
jugé aujourd'hui était accusé d'avoir
lancé des bouteilles et des pierres sur
des policiers laissant un brigadier à
l'épaule cela n'a pas été retenu
finalement il est accusé aussi d'avoir
donné des coups à un policier et surtout
d'avoir craché du sang au visage d'un
autre policier en criant qu'il était
séropositif c'est cela qui lui a valu la
peine de prison avec sursis et la lourde
indemnisation on écoute l'avocat de deux
des policiers qui ont porté plainte mais
c'est une peine assez satisfaisante
parce que le tribunal a fait la part des
choses il l'a relaxé partiellement sur
certaines des infractions pour
lesquelles il était poursuivi il l'a
condamné pour les violences commises
sur mes clients et qu'on peut voir
d'ailleurs à travers les images et la
peine d'avertissement est tout à fait
normal je dirais six mois de prison avec
sursis pour ce genre de passage à l'acte
et de comportements de violence envers
les policiers au sein d'une
manifestation parce que je rappelle que
mon client
malgré cette vidéo où on a fait dire ce
qu'on a voulu dire mais qui correspond
donc on n'est pas la réalité parce que
toujours une question d'angle et de ce
qui peut se passer avant et après et
même pendant mon client lui bénéficier
d'un classement sans suite parce que les
coups qu'on peut voir sont parfaitement
légitimes et justifiées
alors que ce que ne disait pas la
défense ça m'intéressait et qu'on a pu
voir minitieusement sur ces vidéos c'est
que il a craché dans la bouche au visage
de mon client cet incident avait défrayé
la chronique car lors de son
interpellation le jeune homme a été
filmée recevant des coups au visage
alors qu'il était maintenu au sol coups
donnés par l'un des policiers qui a
porté plainte
la vidéo était devenue virale du fait de
sa violence
elle avait même suscité une réaction du
ministre de l'intérieur de l'époque
christophe castaner et à la barre le
jeune homme a reconnu le coup sur le
casque d'un policier pour défendre un
manifestant interpellé mais pour le
reste il a contesté
on le voit sur les vidéos être matraque
et saigné abondamment
ensuite il dit avoir été menacés de mort
insulté pas soigner ce qui explique
selon lui un unique rachat sur le
policier par peur de versions
contradictoires mais la justice a
tranché en le relaxant de certains chefs
d'inculpation mais en le jugeant
coupable des violences restez avec nous
dans quelques instants nous reviendrons
sur le break site cinq ans après le
référendum
les britanniques sont toujours autant
divisés sur la question et puis nous
parlerons du sommet international à
berlin consacrée à la libye principal
enjeu garantir la tenue simultanée
d'élections présidentielle et
législatives le 24 décembre
[Musique]
pour beaucoup le foot a été synonyme
d'évasion durant cette période de la
pandémie
quel est le rôle justement du football
dans notre société en temps de crise
je pense que ça a été bien de continuer
le football pour s'évader à eux aussi au
niveau au niveau mental
on est tous conscients que le football
ligne et tout ce qui est au niveau
social surtout au niveau culture et quel
regard portez-vous sur toutes ces années
à monaco à la juventus en équipe de
france
le football le football c'est ma vie et
le football m'a beaucoup donné en temps
dans tous les contextes et quand on a la
chance de revenir en étant ambassadeur
voir les gens
nous reconnaître les choses qu'on a fait
et non surtout au niveau au niveau
football et ça c'est au champion
bienvenue à novossibirsk heures nous
sommes au bord de la volga le plus long
fleuve d'europe
nous sommes chez vox harry
allons faire connaissance
vous avez choisi le jour à ba et là on
est alors je suis arrivé en 2005 pour
étudier dernière fois celle en profiter
en 2011
elle ne demande pas un petit peu non ah
oui et c'est tous les fromages tous les
soucis sont toutes les décroissants la
pâtisserie traits de caractère des
russes qui te plaît l'amitié les gens
les gens très stylée les français ne
savent pas je ne pensais jamais de ma
vie faire la courge et autonomie vous
pouvez me souhaiter bon courage
à très bientôt sur arte france
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus une pauvre
de défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous savez
pour moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y a pas
d'alternative on sort du politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autorités assez
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
déçu l'univers l'uniforme c'est quand
même des hommes comment ces mecs-là
arrive à dormir la nuit là aussi je
pense qu'on a vécu quelque chose d'inouï
tg les gens ne s'étaient des valeurs de
droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent saison
qu'il avait envie de transmettre quelque
chose à leurs enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas un oubli
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est en direct
il y a quand même la liberté je vous
remercie d'avoir un huitième
[Musique]
votre fonction c'est évidemment de
permettre la liaison entre les
entreprises et le marché local
nous avons créé un outil qui nous permet
d'avoir accès aux plus hautes autorités
de l'état français de l'état russe et
qui nous permet d'améliorer le climat
d'investissement aussi comment vous
sentez la façon dont les entreprises
vont se redresser vont rebondir
elle veut en bons d un d'abord
spécifiquement sur la france la france
est un investisseur extrêmement
important aussi parce que nous sommes le
second investisseur en cumulé
nous sommes le premier employeur
étranger et nous avons plus de 1200
entreprises françaises présentes en
russie
l'attraction elle et culturels tels que
je ne pense pas qu'ils aient le pays
plus proches pour nos amis russes que la
france parce que culturellement nous
sommes identiques
c'est beaucoup plus simple pour des rues
de faire des navets reggae français que
avec les pays voisins
ep
[Musique]
21h30 soyez les bienvenus en direct sur
rt francs si vous nous rejoignez c'était
il ya cinq ans déjà jour pour jour le
référendum du break 6 52% des électeurs
britanniques voter alors en faveur de la
sortie du royaume-uni de l'ue eux
si aujourd'hui le divorce est effectif
les britanniques restent divisés sur le
sujet françois xavier lambert
des milliers de drapeaux britanniques
s'agitent devant le parlement de
westminster ce 1er février 2020 à minuit
les partisans du brésil célèbre la
sortie du royaume uni de l'union
européenne le pays met ainsi un terme à
près de 50 ans passés au sein de l'ue
est en changement de cap qui réjouit des
millions de personnes enfin le pays
s'est réuni à nous avons voté la
démocratie a gagné c'est une grande
victoire pour la démocratie c'est cela
qu'il s'agit
pendant trois ans et demi les élites
nous ont ignorés et nous ont dit vous ne
saviez pas vraiment pourquoi vous votiez
nous savions tous exactement pourquoi
nous votions est aujourd'hui la
démocratie a été mise en place dans ce
pays et pour un pays qui a donné la
démocratie à une grande partie du monde
qui est si si importante
ce dénouement survient presque quatre
ans après l'ondé de choc initial
provoqué par le résultat du référendum
du 23 juin 2016
ce jour là 52% des britanniques ont dit
oui à la rupture avec l'union européenne
un résultat qui porte en partie la
marque de nigel farrage et de son parti
d'alors le you keep qui ont mené une
campagne intense en faveur d'un départ
de lieux
osons désormais rêver que l'aube se lève
sur un royaume uni indépendant
à l'issue d'une période de transition et
de la négociation dans la douleur d'un
accord commercial
le royaume uni a donc définitivement
quitté l'union européenne le 1er janvier
dernier pour londres
le brésil doit permettre une meilleure
maîtrise de l'immigration une plus
grande libéralisation de son économie et
un meilleur accès aux marchés extérieurs
mais le chef du gouvernement britannique
la sur cette décision bénéficiera
également aux états membres de l'ue
c'est horrible c'est je pense un bon
accord pour l'ensemble de l'europe ainsi
que pour nos amis et partenaires
car selon moi ce ne sera pas une
mauvaise chose pour l'union européenne
d'avoir à sa porte un royaume unie
prospère dynamique et heureux ce sera
une bonne chose cela apportera des
emplois et de la prospérité sur
l'ensemble du continent malgré
l'optimisme affiché par downing street
les retombées économiques positives
attribue au brésil se font attendre
depuis le début de l'année les échanges
commerciaux entre l'archipel est le
continent où chuté de 25%
l'unité du royaume uni c'est quand elle
davantage fissurer en écosse les
indépendantistes veulent tant profité
pour faire avancer leur cause tandis que
les unionistes nord-irlandais s'estiment
trahis par le texte de l'accord conclu
avec bruxelles
il dénonce notamment des taxes
douanières qui pourrait raviver les
tensions avec la république d'irlande
membres de lieux alors que de nombreux
aspects techniques doivent encore être
discutées le royaume uni et l'union
européenne vont donc devoir repenser
leurs relations
des liens qui conservent leur proximité
malgré les dissensions politiques plus
de 5 millions d'européens ont ainsi
demandé à pouvoir continuer de résider
au royaume uni malgré le brésil et pour
en parler nous sommes en direct depuis
londres avec martin mc cauley analyse
politique c'est notre rubrique vu de
l'extérieur ce soir
bonsoir martin mc colis merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france 5 ans
donc après ce référendum alors je sais
que la question est vaste mais je fais
confiance à 21 ce prix de synthèse quel
bilan peut-on en tirer bleus qui jean
fauque chick litt relativiser le royaume
car l'angleterre n'a plus qu'à
l'emporter pour le départ femmes et
écosse et l'île du nord reste et sein de
l'union donne pour savoir si elle
souhaite rester au sein je crois donc
c'est une période d'inquiétude extrême
pour le gouvernement à londres car en
écosse on semble devoir d'indépendance
le gouvernement a dit qu'il n'y aurait
pas de vote jusqu'aux prochaines
élections
les catégories non romains représentent
la majorité des populations pour la
première fois en irlande du nord de
l'irlande du nord souhaitait un
référendum sur l'addition ou l'arrêt
adhésion avec la république d'irlande
alors cela serait possible il n'y a pas
de demande pour le moment pour les c'est
une possibilité dans l'ariège proches il
pourrait y avoir une requête de
référendum sur la question du
rapprochement de l'irlande du nord et de
la république d'irlande et il pourrait y
avoir une nouvelle irlande unie ce qui
n'est plus le cadre de vie de plusieurs
décennies
le point positif du rexy c'est que le
gouvernement britannique peut renforcer
la recherche sur la vaccination vague du
web du juge il ya eu elle a une
production très rapide de vaccins plus
d'un quart d'heure
non ont été vaccinées c'est considéré
comme un grand avantage est une étape
positive
le point négatif c'est la perte de
confiance envers le gouvernement les
institutions gouvernementales
le système judiciaire et cetera car il
ya du temps de division les gens ne sont
plus prêts à écouter le point de vue
d'autrui au coq on a une culture du
groupe grandissante des politiques
culturelles etc
non il ya beaucoup de conflits au sein
de la société vue concernant les points
de vue sur des personnes il ya il n'y a
plus de confiance très peu de confiance
et c'est une très mauvaise chose pour la
démocratie clairement problème de
confiance fragilité fébrilité au niveau
de l'ecosse et du dossier l'irlande du
nord boris johnson néanmoins voit les
points positifs
il a dit que cette sortie se braque site
avait permis de réussir la campagne de
vaccination mais également la mise en
place de nouveaux accords commerciaux
donc sur le plan économique vous
partagez ce
d'optimisme du premier ministre s'il a
quitté nantes et 5
il ya cinq ans j'avais demandé à quitter
le pen vous m'aviez demandé il ya cinq
ans combien de temps il faudrait pour
que le royaume uni se réhabitue à la vie
sans union européenne je vais d'ici cinq
ans mais cela va nécessiter encore cinq
ans au regard de nombreux problèmes
n'ont pas encore été résolus
la relation par exemple l'union
européenne reste en suspens mais il ya
effectivement un traité de libre-échange
avec l'australie et le royaume uni ont
visage de négocier avec que les pays du
pacifique un nouveau traité de libre
échange du point de vue commercial c'est
une très bonne nouvelle et karaboué tous
les accords avec d'autres états dans le
monde entier sans devoir passer par
bruxelles
je me dis c'est considéré comme un point
très positif selon un site et un sondage
de l'institut samantha les britanniques
seraient désormais davantage enclins à
rester dans lieux 51% pour 49% contre
vous l'avait dit en début de cette
interview savons vraiment là la division
qui règne encore au royaume-uni ça veut
dire que ceux qui n'étaient pas
convaincus ne le sont toujours pas et
vice versa et le cd 58 et tu es passé de
49 à 51 %
donc cela veut dire certaines personnes
ont changé d'avis
la cause de cela c'est le manque de
confiance envers le gouvernement avait
dit que la situation s'améliorait que
tout marche très très bien après l'offre
existe et ça n'a pas été le cas il ya
beaucoup de conflits avec une antenne au
sein du bagad une fois de plus je
souhaite ont insisté sur le manque de
confiance gouvernement notamment dans
cette ère de la copie 19 à changer de
politique
encore et encore en annexe ii et quand
je dis que le premier ministre se
contredit d'un jour sur l'autre
donc comme cela on va commandes de
confiance envers le gouverneur lambine
bridge s'il n'y avait pas eu de prix qui
est plus de confiance mais le président
a divisé le pays et le gouvernement on
doit trouver et épauler indiqué qu'ils
pourront le fédérer alors je vous donne
deux gars en confiance le pays ne peut
pas avancer
du point de vue économique et politique
merci beaucoup donc affaire à suivre
effectivement
merci à vous monsieur mcconaughey
d'avoir été avec nous pour vu de
l'extérieur ce soir
un nouveau sommet international consacré
à la libye il se dérouler cet après-midi
à berlin la capitale allemande
tous les acteurs de la région sont
réunis avec pour la première fois la
présence du gouvernement de transition
libyen une réunion au niveau des
ministres des affaires étrangères
principal enjeu garantir la tenue
simultanée des élections présidentielle
et législatives le 24 décembre sera
aussi abordé la question de la présence
des forces étrangères quelques heures
avant le début des échanges le
secrétaire d'état américain a demandé la
retrait était l'accord de cessez le feu
du 23 octobre doit être pleinement
appliqué notamment par le retrait de
toutes les forces étrangères de lille i
would be et sur le terrain l'heure est à
l'apaisement entre les belligérants
témoin de la réouverture du principal
axe routier qui relie le pays d'ouest en
est
grégoire dos et le premier ministre
libyen emploie les grands moyens
c'est à la manoeuvre d'un tractopelle
qu'abdelhamid bemba a dégagé en personne
trois barrages de sable qui participait
à bloquer un long tronçon d'une route
côtière qui traverse la libye d'ouest en
est de la frontière tunisienne à la
frontière égyptienne
en ce jour béni est historique nous
participons à l'ouverture du principal
axe vital qui relie l'est et l'ouest de
notre pays et qui facilite la
communication entre les peuples du nord
et du sud
mon cher peuple depuis cette tribune
j'appelle tous nos frères et nos fils à
renoncer à la division à oublier les
rancunes et à avancer vers la
reconstruction
une partie de la route reste fermé et
contrôlé par les forces du maréchal
haftar écarté des négociations qui ont
abouti à l'actuel gouvernement d'unité
nationale mais cela reste un pas
important vers la pacification du pays
alors qu'a lieu ce mercredi la deuxième
conférence sur la paix en libye à berlin
sous l'égide de l'onu au programme les
élections prévues en fin d'année et le
retrait des troupes étrangères
actuellement présente dans le pays
l'accent sera mis sur les préparatifs en
vue des élections prévues le 24 décembre
et le retrait prévu selon les termes du
cessez le feu des troupes étrangères et
des mercenaires de libye les mesures
visant à unifier les forces de sécurité
libyennes seront également discutés les
libyens espèrent que le gouvernement de
transition sera ouvrir la voie à un
avenir plus serein après une décennie de
chaos politique depuis la chute de
mouammar kadhafi
pour en parler nous sommes avec l'autre
blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales bonsoir claude
blanchemaison ce sommet international
est ce que selon vous constituez
véritablement une étape décisive pour la
transition politique en libye
oui cette réunion de berlin qui
d'ailleurs était assez court s'il ya pas
grand chose à négocier a rendu tout à
fait sensible le fait qu'un processus de
paix était en cours et qu'il progresser
sous l'égide des nations unies
ce processus avance à son rythme il est
très complexe parce que la situation en
libye est très complexe et
on l'a vu l'année dernière la recherche
d'un cessez le feu qui avait été conclu
en juillet et qui finalement n'a été
signé par toutes les parties qu'au mois
d'octobre
on a vu aussi ce processus tout à fait
particulier soixante quinze
personnalités éminentes libyennes ont
été assiégés ensemble à genève pendant
plusieurs jours pour désigner ce premier
ministre du gouvernement unifié de
transition ainsi que trois personnes
d'un conseil de l'état libyen qui est
notamment responsable de toutes les
questions de sécurité
ce processus fonctionne puisque ce
gouvernement unifié de transition a été
installé au mois de mars et que le
premier ministre a fait plusieurs
voyages dont un voyage à paris est un
voyage à rome et qu'aujourd'hui il était
à berlin alors les deux questions qui
étaient sur la table à vers là
aujourd'hui
c'était le retrait des troupes
étrangères qu'il s'agisse de troupes
régulières et oyonnax notamment turcs ou
de mercenaires et il y en a aussi de
diverses origines et la ministre des
affaires étrangères du gouvernement
unifié de transition or gérard marx en
libye une ministre des affaires
étrangères ça n'est pas rien déjà comme
résultat a indiqué que des contacts
avaient lieu notamment entre les turcs
et les russes pour que les milices
syriennes qui avaient été amenés et dans
certaines combattait d'un côté d'autres
de l'autre soit retirée peut-être 300 de
chaque côté dans les prochains jours
dans quelque chose est en train de se
passer
mais on dit qu'il y a probablement 20
mille combattants étrangers miliciens
étrangers sur le sol libyen et il faut
qu'il parte ce sera difficile puisque
l'ancien gouvernement soutenu par l'onu
n'avait dû son salut en réalité qu'à
l'intervention de la turquie puisque le
maréchal haftar avait failli prendre
tripoli en 2019 2020
le deuxième sujet qui a été évoquée
aujourd'hui c'est en effet ces
déductions élections présidentielle et
législatives
le 24 décembre prochain certains
trouvent que c'est un peu tôt en tout
cas il y a eu unanimité aujourd'hui pour
maintenir cette date ces dates objectif
le 24 décembre prochain c'est très
important parce que dix ans après la
chute du régime de kadhafi
je crois que la population les bienne
aspire à aspire à la paix alors malgré
tout que le blanchemaison quels sont les
obstacles sont nombreux j'imagine qui
subsistent effectivement il y en a
beaucoup
les 20 cas d'obstacle juridique qui est
que un autre comité à rédiger une
constitution une nouvelle constitution
pour la libye
mais cette constitution il faut la
soumettre à référendum et jusqu'à
présent on ne sait pas très bien quand
elle sera soumise à référendum
peut-être d'ailleurs le 24 décembre en
même temps que l'élection présidentielle
est l'initiative est un peu curieux
d'avoir des élections et de ne pas avoir
la constitution la règle du jeu
auparavant la deuxième difficulté elle
et les politiques c'est que le premier
ministre de transition trouve peut-être
que les lettres un peu court jusqu'au 24
décembre plus qu'en principe et il ne
veut il ne se présentera pas à
l'élection du 24 mai aux élections du 24
décembre
et puis la difficulté elle elle est
aussi de nature sécuritaire
le maréchal haftar il y a quatre jours
était à la tête de 2000 véhicules dans
le sud du fezzan parce que il y avait
semble-t-il des terroristes qui se
manifestait au sud de la libye
et d'ailleurs ce n'est pas étonnant
puisque le sud de la libye est une zone
de non droit et que c'est probablement
de là que venait les adversaires du
président idriss déby et qui ont tué le
président idriss deby dans le nord du
tchad
enfin il ya aussi des problèmes
d'organisation de ces élections qui
reviennent naturellement au gouvernement
de transition mais qui pose des
problèmes considérables et puis il ya
évidemment le fait que les pays
extérieurs peuvent aussi avoir leur idée
sur qui sera président de la république
sur qui sera premier ministre et qu'il
dit interviennent en coulisses pour
faire progresser telle ou telle
candidature pour le moment il y a quatre
candidats mais il y en aura certainement
plus dont d'ailleurs un des fils de
kadhafi
et puis à un personnage qui a été
ministre de l'intérieur très puissants
jusqu'à la prise de fonction du
gouvernement de transition
et puis le maréchal haftar lui-même qui
sera très probablement candidat ni
l'europe dans tout ça claude blanche
maison et bien l'europe qui étaient
présentes naturellement à cette réunion
de berlin comme elle était présente à la
première réunion de berlin il ya 18 mois
époque où il n'y avait pas de
gouvernement de transition époque où on
était un petit peu nulle part l'europe
attache une très grande importance à
avoir un interlocuteur stable à tripoli
parce que la libye est la voisine de
l'europe et que beaucoup de migrants
parts sur la mer méditerranée des côtes
libyennes et se dirige dans des
conditions de précarité tout à fait
scandaleuse vers l'italie alors il ya
des accords entre l'union européenne et
la libye entre l'italie et la libye pour
former les garde-côtes libyens et pour
qui les empêchent de partir tous ces
migrants qui en réalité sont pris en
main par des passeurs par des mafias de
passeurs qui prennent des sommes
considérables pour mettre ces migrants
qui viennent parfois d'ailleurs de la
zone sahélienne sur des esquifs et les
lancers vers la méditerranée bien
souvent vers la mort donc pour l'union
européenne c'est un enjeu très important
que de pouvoir maîtriser ces flux de
migrants en traitant avec un gouvernent
il est bien qu'il y ait un gouvernement
stable est là pour ça des moyens
importants notamment des moyens de
coopération des moyens de formation
et puis l' agence frontex dont c'est
aussi la mission
merci beaucoup claude blanchemaison
d'avoir été avec nous et dans le reste
dans le reste de l'actualité en afrique
en mauritanie précisément l'ancien
président mohamed ould abdel aziz a été
arrêté hier soir et placé en détention
par un juge du pôle anticorruption du
pays
en mars dernier il avait été inculpé
pour corruption détournement de biens
publics et blanchiment d'argent
yamina benguigui da il a dirigé la
mauritanie pendant plus de dix ans de
2008 à 2010 9 hier soir mohamed ould
abdel aziz ex président mauritanien a
été placé en détention
une décision qui intervient après le
refus de l'ancien chef d'état de se
présenter à la police comme le lui
imposer des conditions de son
assignation à résidence
son avocat dénonce une décision
arbitraire
c'est une décision qui viole toutes les
lois de la procédure pénale
on va montrer que ce n'est qu'une
vengeance et que cela n'a aucune base
juridique
mohamed ould abdel aziz a été inculpé le
2 mars dernier en même temps qu'une
dizaine de hautes personnalités pour des
faits présumés de corruption blanchiment
d'argent et enrichissement illicite ou
encore dilapidation de biens publics
commis pendant les années où il était au
pouvoir
un mois après ces accusations il
réagissait tous les moyens matériels et
humains ont été utilisés pour me viser
de façon arbitraire
l'unique raison expliquant tout cela
c'est de m'empêcher de faire de la
politique
très vite une commission parlementaire
écrit pour examiner sa gouvernance
durant sa décennie de présidence
certains faits sont alors révélé
l'enquète parlementaires accusent ainsi
l'ancien chef d'état d'avoir notamment
cédé une île à un souverain étranger
en effet la commission a mis la main sur
une note de l'ambassadeur du qatar en
mauritanie datant du 12 janvier 2012
dans laquelle il fait état d'une offre
de cession de cet îlot situé dans la
zone du parc national du banc d'arguin
un site classé au patrimoine mondial de
l'unesco
le nom de l'ancien président a été
maintes fois directement cité dans le
cadre de faits et d'actes pouvant
constituer une atteinte dangereuse à la
constitution et aux lois mauritanienne
un magistrat du parquet s'exprimant sous
couvert de l'anonymat
ainsi que le porte parole du parti de
mohamed ould abdel aziz et ancien
ministre dibril ould bilal ont confirmé
son placement sous mandat de dépôt sans
s'attarder sur sa cause c'est la fin de
cette émission merci de l'avoir suivi
prochain point complet sur l'actualité
ce sera dans quelques minutes avec
pierre pissavy yvernault
[Musique]
l'idée